[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to another
gameplay for all charity stream I'm so
excited about this one we are gonna be
playing Red Dead online with the cast of
Red Dead Redemption - we have some
fantastic guests today so I'm gonna
start from top it's weird because I'm
feel like we're the Brady Bunch
Roger Clark who plays obviously Arthur
Morgan
hi thank you so much for joining us
Alex McKenna you play Sadie Adler oh my
best girl from Red Dead - Ben Byron
Davis who of course plays a man the myth
the legend dutch finaland thank you for
having me and joining us as well we've
got our very own jake decker huge Red
Dead fan and you might know him from
dirty arty his let's play series yep
played a lot I read that so I'm very
excited because obviously we have we've
got the cast and it's gonna basically be
jake and i trying desperately not to do
Red Dead voices the whole time well T's
amount well choose them out before we
get started in the game we are raising
money for two very special causes we're
raising money for black lives matter and
Direct Relief who provide help to
frontline health care workers here
battling the covert 19 pandemic so the
links are on screen it's bit dot ly /g
Ovid ly / GS - BL em and if you're gonna
donate which please do please give if
you can't donate right now please
promote the stream promote these causes
we will get the cast read out your
donations and honestly we had a zoom
call the other day to help set all this
up and gonna be like me or Jake you'll
kind of melt when you hear them say your
name like
Redemption so please do it we're gonna
have a lot of fun on the stream today
I'll be looking at YouTube chat if you
have questions please throw him a posse
so should we talk about this the big
decision that we had to make what I
posses colds who came up with a demand
probably was rather yeah
where are the Friends of Gavin don't ask
us if we've seen him yet we just get the
fight feeling that he's a really nice
guy he must be a great friend he has
someone looking out for him all the time
yeah certainly made an impression uh
Jake where are you so we're looking at
Jake's game play right now I'm at the
camp should I should we take a look at
everyone's character so we can see all
right sure and you'll notice that we
have hidden who keeps joining us and who
keeps trying to kill us all is the sixth
member of the Friends of Gavin yeah yeah
so it's got been right here and we've
got wait I'm gonna Willie no I'll do a
prospector jig there you go and then
we've got Roger right here hello and
then we've got Lucy right here who is
standing in for Alex yeah so I'm playing
for Alex cuz we had some technical
difficulties getting everyone together
so I'm gonna be Alex's proxy I'm
hopefully gonna do your name right uh
Jeff and my horse Jeff too so there are
a few things that I would love for us to
do like there's obviously so much to do
in Red Dead online there's some missions
do we want to start and go go see Sadie
they're not that far away actually
they're just up here so I've set a
weight point on the map who is shooting
the hidden if that is you know I shot
hidden
which one is sages house oh yeah it's
the one up there in the top so Friends
of Gavin let's roll up my sleeve hidden
finally probably ambushed us on the way
out of here
oh he's shooting at me he's mad at me
alright what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
activate cinematic cam and have me run
that way and I'll take a look at the
chat and donations we've already had
some come in actually so let me read
those out or one which is fantastic
thank you so much okay so also I hope
everyone's proud of me that I have not
said we've got a plan I've got a plan
that's how I should have said this stuff
I should have been like I've got a play
and Arthur well first of all holy [ __ ]
Anonymous has donated a thousand dollars
to direct you really anonymous that's
amazing
way to set the bar high thank you that's
also whatever the plan was it's
definitely working millennion let's
let's get some uh oh wow we had a few
okay so okay Matt Hawking $10 I saw Matt
thank you Matt Roxane limo girl $25 oh
you guys are amazing aren't fans the
best
Dead fans the best Jorge Castro $25 I'm
gonna assume this is not ex England
rugby player Jonny Wilkinson but maybe
it is
Wilkinson $25 thank you thank you and
Delaney Tola $10 Posse I don't know if
I've got a nice warm winter jacket to
visit you Alex I think Roger and I got a
bit ahead of everyone else okay
he was shooting at me but he stops maybe
he yeah maybe shift focus um you guys I
didn't see he had a horse so it
shouldn't be hard I stole his hat I
that's what that's what kicked it all
off I think oh my gosh I forgot how
quicker the course go down online okay
I'm gonna turn off notifications quickly
thank you Eric
voice of God if you've seen a lot of us
dreams you'll see you'll have heard Eric
in the back in the past yeah nice one uh
okay all right we're almost there
oh we had a bunch more come through on
Direct Relief too awesome
one second let's get to the ranch
oh hi everyone hey guys just a random
guy is that hidden again no it's just
follow
it's friendly fire okay I'm coming up
where's Jeff I have some tonic you
should be okay okay
Delvin s Morris five dollars helicopter
I think this came to the rescue
yeah he was our guardian angel
I think your man had a nice horse though
okay
Travie Thank You Trevor copter
okay I've healed up Jeff um where were
we anonymous $1 I Swan Thank You
Christine magnet $5 awesome
Christina what Christine Christian sorry
this gym thank you uh Delaney Tola love
all of you thank you so much for this
[Music]
$25 audio - is life that was our
original Posse name before but without
Rosie looks like I'm not gonna get cold
enough we have Olli Taurus oh god
they're coming all eat our is $20 so
glad you guys are playing together are
we hoping to see author finally take
down Dutch $20 from anonymous great
thank you
we always joke every time we get an
anonymous donation that it's the
hacktivist group
they're wearing a V for Vendetta mask
and don't that sounds like a good thing
and John Furman $20 $10 love you guys
pretty good it right in quotes to
anonymous yeah that's the first dad joke
of the day I'm gonna sure everyone it
will not be the last
look you're among friends here I want to
hear more of those jokes
check out that scenery man I've been on
lastima stew so I haven't played this
it's every time you play it you try to
turn it back on you forget how gorgeous
it is
I'm not playing but I love watching it
it's fully like an interactive film we
were talking yesterday about you know
like playing the game again and I just
got my PC and so now I'm like oh but
what if I haven't played it on PC I
haven't I haven't got it downloaded just
yet I'm gonna I'm gonna wait until the
play froze running for another couple
weeks and then I've got some time off
and so that's kind of my favorite way to
play Red Dead is like in big long
stretches when you get lost in it it's
just hard to whack it on for a half an
hour isn't it yeah I distracted and I
played a good amount on PC and I just
ended up spending most the time taking
pictures because like we were saying
earlier it's just so gorgeous
and every second I just stopped freeze
the game figure out what angle I wanted
to take some pictures and that that was
like it took me so much longer some of
those shots are amazing attacked in
photo mode and I guess I just got I
bought this horse yesterday and I just
got up to level 2 Oh easy
feed you I was gonna I was gonna buy a
new horse and then but I I remembered
all the good times that Jeff two and I
have had and I just couldn't do that to
him
okay these are amazing more donations
Hallet divers direct sea
I'm sorry if I could you the Penn
Station renamed Holly Holly it says
gives $50 and says Red Dead was a
complete experience for me and remains
my favorite game of all time I would
just like to say thank you to the cast
for that hard work and everyone who
worked on the game for that dedication
by chance could I hear but Ben say
ladies and gentlemen this is a robbery
absolutely thanks for the support of the
charity and thanks for mentioning
everybody that it took to make red dead
there's about two thousand I think
people that worked on the second game so
the request I got it ladies and
gentlemen this is a robbery
amazing yes no man this is a robbery
I kind of like that is he Blues $10 much
love from the GTA forums question have
you guys had the pleasure of meeting
woody Jackson and what is your favorite
piece of music from the original score
of the game I was kind of overwhelmed
because I've been listening to this
guy's music since the first Reds an
invention Wow yeah he's absolutely
amazing my favorite I love what is it
called um it'll come to me when you tell
your story first
just what do you Jackson is friends with
the friend of mine Rory Cochrane and so
we know of each other but his work is so
tremendous and
my favourite thing is whenever I've seen
videos of his process how much he
invests in the instruments that he
chooses to play and how I think some of
the sounds really are almost like
characters that he finds in the score
it's really remarkable watches do you
remember the piece of music
it's like unleashed this great this
great string section on it oh it's
insane yeah outlaws from the West I mean
you really can't go wrong no things went
poorly the last time I was here before
we've got a bunch of donations so before
we go in and meet Sadie and Alex I'm
gonna ask you I'm gonna ask all of you
as we kind of go through like what your
experience was like working on the game
so let's blast through these donations
and then and then go in and see Sadie
and Jake so uh teenie gives five dollars
with I think I think let's get the best
Gavin from everyone if we can please
that message is just a very good British
accent Sam D gives ten dollars the three
of you did fantastic jobs in what is in
my opinion the most memorable game of
the decade you're all good boys forty
dollars for my very own tamale stain and
this he's regretting I know that guy
he's awesome spot on Twitter - he's very
funny I he requests can I get Roger Alex
and been to each say the phrase I want
to be a cowboy baby
Oh baby
that's that I say is it I Alex
well I am a cowboy baby hell yeah yeah I
I want to be a cowboy baby I am a cowboy
we got $30 from Lennie my boy shall
Wilson thanks for this love Red Dead
Redemption two outlaws for life Rachel
and Liam $10 please say hi to Salem the
bunny hey same bunny how I jacquelyn's
gives $100 Red Dead Redemption to you
got me through some dark times so you
guys mean a lot to me lots of love be
well and get to Tahiti yeah definitely
so I will mark it there let's let's do a
little bit of a a mission and then we
will all right so come in for
blacklivesmatter so people can fast so a
couple from black lives matter
Erica Brooks ten dollars William
Abbott's
25 bucks others named Richie boy Rekha
monta a very young boy named two black
lives matter so thank you so much
phenomenal oh you're wearing t-shirt
Alex yeah yeah
Cheryl Wilson also gave $100 Wow Cheryl
that's awesome
yeah and Rebecca Smith $25 of my lies
Meza Rebecca you're alright girl
all right there are still loads will
coming in we will get to you but let's
let's do a little mission guys let's all
right no everyone what the Friends of
Gavin are made of but let's call in on
Sadie my best girl you have to go into
the back trust drifters not wear stolen
I'm scared looking in case this place
gets round but I'll pay a decent for it
so we're near Lake Isabella be safe now
okay feels kind of what's the point
getting the dead man's wagon back for
well that's just a big fan of Patrick
Callahan and the chat says damn this
Roger Clark guy kind of sounds like
awesome writers thanks thanks yeah
alright do get that a little bit every
now and then so Alex I'm gonna come to
you I mean what what impact has being in
Red Dead had on your life question I
would say that we worked on the game for
five years together creating this so in
addition to truly creating this family
like a bit there there my thermic gang
they're my brothers they're my family
that's we created this we were so so
fortunately playing your surfboard in
Norfolk
directors and everybody who went into
the game and we spent hours upon hours
when full motion capture together so
that meant that we were in our suits on
a soundstage so it was more
theater-in-the-round
than just you know doing voiceover which
is often somehow or how it gets
presented but in fact we were we were
doing
theater together just being filmed by a
lot of different cameras I think once I
said I was like mm cameras right I think
they were about what was that yeah it
was amazing I mean it's it's been such a
privilege to be part of the Rockstar
family and to get to meet people that
connect with the game and to hear their
stories about how they loved it how it
got them through a hard time and I'm
just so grateful and also to get to play
Sadie Adler you know maybe one of the
coolest female characters of all time
pretty pretty honored what did you know
so when when you got the role what did
you how much about the game did you know
is in like did you know is Red Dead -
did you know
Sadie's position in the game and no it
took me about two years actually of
working on the game because it was
sporadic so we would work
you know maybe five days and then
nothing for a couple months and then
this does for me and it was very
different for Roger and for Ben but I
you know so it took me about two years I
I don't know if I'm allowed to say what
it was called on the thing but yeah I
figured pretty quickly it was Western
but I really just I didn't know to put
it together and I figured it was safer
for me not to try to figure it out until
it became pertinent to how I was going
to play this character and so he would
sneak around sometimes at lunch be like
can I see your sights can I read this
can we and we were trying it all
together and then once it became very
clear that Sadie was a real part of the
gang
I got to watch some of her development
and piece together how she was going to
progress throughout the story that's
when it all started to come together and
it made it so much more fun to to make
choices but the directors and the
writers I mean everybody worked so
closely I mean we were very very
fortunate there was a real mission and
we were given colors to paint with and
then they said alright do you think it
was great so it was all the filming all
the recording done in LA or I mean how
often would the whole gang get together
well we rented one we did it all in in
Santa Monica though but Red Dead 2 was
in New York State so those was Steve J
Palmer and I think at a certain point
Alex and I we would have to commute out
for the shoots from Los Angeles and it
would be it wasn't always that we would
all be together there but those days
we're always really really special then
everybody cuz probably be coming from
out of this state and we'd all sort of
get together and those of us that were
traveling from out of state tended to
stay in the same hotel so we'd be
running lines at night the hotel bar and
being doing our best to keep everything
under wraps and it became quite a
fundraiser well every time we'd get
together just remarkable but I miss
everybody terribly but it's very this is
reminding me of some fun days yeah it's
good to see you all again and it's good
to play rented as well it's not because
we you know we were working away and
slaving away at it for years but you
know all the amazing departments they
are to the village like when you say in
earlier all the amazing departments you
know we weren't aware of what they were
doing until the game actually came up
and then we all got to see what everyone
else was working hard about too we were
in ours as Alex causing the superheroes
oh okay yeah no let's kill these guys
yeah I called them are superheroes
scuba-diver suits oh do they have all
the ping pong zone yes yes oh you like
black cat suits with no helmets
if only government could see us now oh
come on with you why is it such a rush
to get that back I've got a really nice
one here a lot of folks in the chat or
for rockstar to add mica as a bounty in
online but doesn't the online universe
take place like a year before yeah
chance to see Peter Bloomquist from work
I would jump in but he's just terrific
so I mean obviously after working in
secrecy for so long and I mean I asked
Alex's but like how have your lives
changed now that you know read dead 2 is
out there and is so beloved and like we
can see in the chat and from the
donations that it has such a such a fan
base who not only love you guys because
if the characters you play but because
of you you are too it's been kind of
it's been overwhelming we we worked on
it like you say in secrecy you know you
didn't want to spoil anything for the
fans so you know as base we're good
we're brother yeah and we're working in
this bubble you know which gave us
really kind of tunnel vision it just
made us concentrate and focus on the
task at hand there's only until after
the game came out
I've a question for Ben what was it like
when like you found out you were working
on Red Dead Redemption too because I
know a lot of fans were asking for it
for years and for a while people were
like are they even gonna do a sequel and
like I guess that moment when I don't
know you got the script or got word from
Rockstar that this was gonna happen what
was your response if you remember it
ah do I remember it yeah I remember it I
was you know the first one was such a
amazing experience and you know a lot of
ways was a dream come true cuz I had I'd
been a gamer and I sort of I had a sense
that actors were part of how these
things were put together and I thought
it looked like a good gig but I didn't
really realize when we were doing the
first one I gonna let other people kill
these guys what we were doing the first
one I didn't really realize how amazing
it was gonna be I didn't know how great
it was gonna be I didn't understand
really the whole scope of duck he's a
character and so when it was over I was
very hopeful that I was going to get a
phone call to come back but I didn't it
wasn't a guarantee and they certainly
you know there hadn't been plans when we
did the original to do that so when I
got that call I was - about as excited
for it's I've been about anything except
for the fact that I didn't you I
couldn't tell anybody that I was doing
it but it changed Jake when I got the
first because I didn't know I mean the
the work I did on the first game was I
think all put it took about six months
but all put together it was maybe a week
or two of performance capture at the
most and then three hours in the booth
but the work I did on Red Dead the first
week I was on Red Dead I did at least
three times as much work as I did on red
and two rather I did three times as much
work as I did on the whole of Red Dead
one
so the I booked the job and then when I
finally signed all the contracts and
they sent me the first hundred pages the
script that I had to memorize
I was both excited I had to get to work
but then I also became a bit intimidated
because I was so proud of the first one
I honestly had some fears that what have
we what do we can't do better and I
shared those fears with our director
Brad etch on the first day of
performance capture and he as he tended
to do put me right at ease and said
we're gonna do better than we did on the
first one and I think he was he was
right although you know what better is
the wrong word because I really think of
them now I was just one piece like I
think it's just one whole aesthetic
whole from top to bottom we all know we
wouldn't have been there if it wasn't
for the amazing work they did in the
previous one but going around to the
conventions and stuff and meeting the
fans you know I can't keep saying hey
you know what being able to work is is
all it's really what it's all about you
know if you're lucky enough to have them
a job and to be able to work as an actor
it's such a blessing but then to be able
to do something that means something to
and is appreciated by I know such a
wonderful bunch of people like all of
the donations we've had today that's
just icing on the cake you guys are
awesome thank you for thank you we
appreciate your appreciation all right
well let this cutscene playing then
we'll read through a few more donations
they have been coming in hot woohoo got
a trophy I did ok so on black lives
matter which is big dot ly / GS - a BLM
Antley in a Robert $2 Angelina thank you
John Furman $10
ja ja $10 wait what was the name I was
talking over you loser oh sorry Jeremy
row Jeremy
James robiola $25
Pamela Jade Martinez $10 I just got I
got booted I think it's my internet uh
Tyler Rodriguez $25
Ramona Smith $25 Rebecca Smith has
donated again $25 there I'm sorry I
wasn't there back I was at a wedding
I love afford $3 Michael Costello $5
thank you thank you Michael yes ma'am
McClain whoa Joe whoa yo $1 nice lon
every dollar counts Morton Jenson $25
Morgan great name Eames everyone has
like an incredible name Susanna Hooda
Cova $25 i Garrett's I bet $5 triple
Rhys $10 verb thank you sir Rhys Makara
$10 Thank You Reese McLean whoa yo
donated another dollar every dollar
counts $10 what was it Shane woods $10
English so they were all for black lives
matter we've got oh wow
so many for Direct Relief - before you
get to that Lucy so we got kicked out of
the posse when you when I got so when
you join back in you'll have to send us
Posse invites okay but continue oh so
we're out in the open now technically we
could shoot each other but
reward um well I do have another
suggestion if you guys want to do
another Sadie and Jake Adler mission
feel free or where are you on the map
because I feel like you could go see um
you could go see Sean Maguire how do we
get the shot though Sean is in Aurora
Basin in tall trees so actually what
might be quite nice is if you go on a
detour through armadillo and kind of
look at the old red dead um so yeah he's
a roar Basin and toll trees so I think I
got it I can lead the way all right
you're gonna wait for you to rejoin or
should we form another Posse with us for
now the posse should be live still it
should be a persistent one so maybe we
just join it left on the d-pad and see
your friends of governor though if I
could just suggest follow me that's
right okay so uh Olivia gave $5 and said
Gavin would be proud of your posse keep
up the good work max Abel puns $10
thanks to the three of you for your work
you changed my life I love you more and
I can explain that best video game ever
Nicole
three one nine five $25 I'm the biggest
fan of audio - I have never been so in
love with the game
Piper Schulman $5 you guys are so
amazing this game means so much to me
thank you very much
Thank You Pfeifer yeah
Oh Garrett says okay $1 just finished
the last of us and I'm wondering what
Roger thought there's no spoilers I
haven't
it's harrowing harrowing ly good but you
know it's it's it's harrowing but the
environment the world and everything
it's absolutely amazing absolutely
amazing and yeah no spoilers the combat
is so dynamic and it's so brutal I'm
enjoying it it's you know it's not a
light-hearted game it's no animal
crossing that's for sure
zedd be $10 thank you all and everyone
behind the scenes for what they've done
the gamble that love exists and do a
loving act and we learned pretty quick
you have to be nice to the animators
otherwise they can make you look like
really dumb did you learn that the hard
way story though bill Holt $20 is a
fourth year of man I just want to say I
really have such an emotional connection
to this game and thank you all so much
any chance we can get Roger to ask is
this a holdup and then to answer it's a
science experiment
Josh Marco tragic that got that guy a
bit from the game as that is not it's
from its from Back to the Future Part
three oh come on Roger oh I totally
missed that reference
all right then is this a holdup no it's
a science experiment
oh that you took my line cheese and Crow
let's take this again from the time I
wasn't clear on the instruction that's
the question is this is this a train
robbery
the science experiment over here okay I
got this I got this
Roger you're gonna say is this a holdup
a been sent it take two
let's just take three now is this a
holdup no it's a science experiment
Hey
$10 beer gives $20 and says it's hot
outside remember to drink some water
that's a very good point and wash your
hands and we're a damn mask darn masks
yeah I can you see chains YouTube's $10
great thing you guys are doing here I
love this game so much and we'll always
love it you're all awesome can I get a
read of can I get a one last job please
who's that
who says you say one more score yeah oh
yeah is that one of the trailer just one
more big score and we'll have enough
money to leave Rob so Rob handler who
does the let's play series dirty arty
with Jake where they try and make Arthur
the biggest POS they possibly can
so what Rob gives $50 good one nice one
good Roger please say in Arthur's voice
yeah that's a good can of beans the
monster gets three dollars love you guys
so much can you say hi to Abdul raha
Abdul Rahman and also I love all the
characters I recognize that name
nice to see you again man glad you're
enjoying it
Jade silver $5 great to see you playing
together I love rented to Raja Ben can
you give me a greeting please big silver
silver all right thank you so hiyo
silver
that's a little ranger reference I guess
it's kind of a dad joke - sorry it's
Jade not Jake okay so much better name
than Jake what kind of name is Jake is
um Holly bourgeois fantastic five
dollars thank y'all so much for the work
you've done in Red Dead this game is the
only thing I found it helps me cope with
my chronic pain I am so thankful for
y'all much love and respect from North
Carolina
Holly the aspiring Rancher hashbrown the
cow and take the dog Tater Tot the calf
that means so much to hear I'll tell you
William Abbott's $20 I already donated
once but can dutch shoutout the posse of
em to frost Robert and a won best game
ever by the way wait a minute I need
some help with that again though em to
frost Robert and a 1 M to frost Robert
and a 1 consider yourselves shout it out
$20 from Richard bar Warnock Red Dead
Redemption is my favorite game thank you
Richard and $20 from JJ and our up today
thank you to everyone that worked on
this beautiful game lots of love from
the Red Dead online retreats
thank you thank you my son came in in
his underwear and asked me to delete
stuff on his minecraft game don't come
in the camera shop
it feels like everybody's logic made the
posse everyone's looking for Gavin yeah
we all are we all looking for Gavin in a
way though I'd say so
our own little Gavin some of us never
find him but it's the journey that
counts I went out looking for Gavin and
what I found was myself yeah so that's
so deep thank you it was pretty deep
my horse is out of stamina so I am
slightly behind you guys I think all
right I'm gonna hold up here and wait
for you stragglers I am just outside a
strawberry
there's a couple other players riding
next to us they both look like they're
cosplaying Arthur Morgan yeah hi guys I
like the piece cool
what's nice if only they knew they were
writing next - Arthur Morgan maybe they
do yeah that's a good point I haven't
been to the old map the read their
original map in a while
rented one came out 10 years ago and
even when I when I played by dead - the
first time and you actually get to go
that I still knew my way around tiny
little differences that you pick up on
like oh that tree isn't as big as it
used
you know but I can I can I think I can
navigate the home map without the HUD
Wow
so when Red Dead so the thing about
returning of the question was asked
earlier because it seems like an
interesting point but when we did the
first Red Dead hey everybody when we did
the first Red Dead all I knew about
Dutch van der Linde from those writers
were that he was a gang leader had been
a gang leader and that he was
extraordinarily literate well-read had
highfalutin ideas about society and he
had lost his mind and that's all I knew
and I hope that he was I thought he was
kind of the big bad in the game but I
didn't really know and I really really
didn't know until I played the game
exactly the dimensions of Dutchess
character which was so my first
playthrough the first read that I was
learning about Dutch a lot more than
people might imagine myself so getting
to revisit him and knowing so much more
about him from the get-go
it was like I said to before a dream
come true
did you uh did you get chills I guess
when you or I don't know when you were
reading the script for Red Dead - and
you do that same exact speech about
gravity yeah like I just remember
getting chills hearing that when I
played there I tell you know I saw that
and I was terrified again yeah I didn't
want um
so much of your work as an actor you're
getting you're getting hired you know I
like to joke about playing big guy
number two which I actually did play the
guy number two and off-center hundred
years ago but so much of the time when
you're working you're you're just you're
getting a job and and you do it and then
you're on to the next job like you don't
usually it's just sort of a gigging
actor you don't always encounter
stuff like we did on on Red Dead so when
you do get to do something that dare I
say we was kind of iconic which was the
first you know that speech at the end of
the first read there the idea that
you're gonna go and mess with it even a
little bit is terrifying and I was
afraid that it wasn't we weren't gonna
pull it off but again when you're
working with rock star you really never
have to worry because if anything
doesn't work they don't use it the
amount of good things that they like a
goal completely well that's too much
information but we did pull it off but I
was I was Jake I was intimidated by
having to live up to the original City
which I guess is probably a good place
to approach things from because you
don't want to be too self-assured I'm
just following up behind you also I will
be there very very shortly
okay I think you do need to send another
posse invite because everyone's showing
up the same color for me I think so too
um did you see in your posse menu Oh
people people are saying Jake feed your
host please I know I don't have anything
I gotta go to the post office I ordered
stuff Roger and I are right together so
Alex earlier you were mentioning it's
like theater so I mean could you kind of
expand on that a little bit more and
like talk about the differences between
you know I guess traditional acting
quote/unquote compared to full
performance capture and maybe the
different challenges that presents I
think one of the greatest challenges in
differences is you know when you're
doing theater you have a set that is how
you imagine it if you can see me in this
little thing you know I'm in an office
here are books it you know I can be this
temperature because the air conditioning
is on and
how that is when you're doing our motion
capture we're a giant soundstage but it
kind of looks like we're on a jungle gym
or it's like a playground and everything
is you know the horses were almost like
an like like beer barrels with plastic
posts and everything is I want to say
rudimentary because it's actually quite
complicated some of it but it's not it's
a lot of a lot of imagination required
let's say and so I think one of the
greatest challenges would be being in
different climates or not knowing what
the train was and needing to figure out
what the scale was for how far away we
were from the water tower and what that
was really going to look like and then
remembering was a cold was it warm how
do we you know inhabit the world that we
literally can't see it looks like we're
just playing on a jungle gym
so scuba suits right yes our super super
heros scuba divers suits um but it was
yeah anyways so we we would be playing
in and we were so fortunate that our
director rod would call the animators I
mean the first time I ever got to see a
rendering I thought my heart was going
to explode it was it was I still
remember the moment chills everywhere I
we haven't seen anything and so they
turned around their little computer and
I was like it was you know very very
early days like such a you know as any
artist knows like early days with their
sketches they wouldn't you know wasn't
as it was going to be but just to see
what was happening because it was only
something that we had ever been I mean
at least for me playing out in my mind I
didn't really know what it was gonna
look like was just it's so inspiring and
very very exciting but I think that's
one of the the greatest challenges that
and the fact that we were wearing these
helmets that have have their microphone
that kind of come
like an arm here and so in any scene
where we have to hug or we would be
climbing all of a sudden you be like oh
I'm stuck oh we would hug and we'd be in
the middle of the scene it would be
creative would be fiery and all the
sudden really Oh waiting for cut okay
okay can we untangle you know those were
those were some of their the challenges
that come to mind but if I I just that's
the label say hi to us say Ben I don't
think you'd read you mind the pasta yet
how do I pre join the class I suppose
hold down on pause options I mean then
what um let me add you again just in
case I think if you hit left on the
d-pad to you can scroll down the posse
and then you should see our posse I
think oh yeah there we go we've got a
posse for a posse we have a ton of
donations thank you everyone who has
been donating so let's get through a
couple of them before we ends before we
go see Sean anonymous $10 Red Dead
Redemption to is my favorite game of all
time but I'm also a big fan of Grand
Theft Auto so I'm curious to know if
you've played GTA and what you think are
the performances of the actors in the
latest entry of the series oh yeah sure
I was playing GTA 5 the whole time we
were working on this be helpful to learn
you know to see that how you would blend
in from cutscenes to gameplay and all
that that was really useful you know nod
Ned and Steve argh and and and Franklin
you know solo they really paved the way
for us you know because the technology
of the mocap just got really really
better over the course of the years that
they were making GTA and read that
through you know so yeah that's an
amazing game we were playing in a lot
the first one we used to play the first
one with the bird's-eye view oh wow back
in the day
yeah GTA 3 oh gosh I remember the first
time I played GTA 3i I did the one of
the taxi missions then I was in college
so I would pick up a passenger and then
I Drive into my garage and I'd lock him
in there for a couple of days you know
and then I open it back up and he try
and run out but I'd get him with him I
don't I don't play like that
wow that guy looks just like Arthur
Morgan David six four three you look
like Arthur Morgan
Simon Hoch steps five dollars waiting
for Red Dead 400 I know because the Red
Dead Revolver nose is stuffed five
dollars I broke my foot yesterday and
this dream is making it feel better
thank you for making Jackie $20 hey guys
just want to say love all of you and the
work you've done outlaws for life we've
got some was it Jack P yeah another 20
bucks for anonymous Katherine fifty
bucks
thank you Audio audio Oh retreat back
again ten dollars thank you for giving
up ps4 community such a wonderful game
to play during the pandemic tag back T V
so they're in they gave $200 to Direct
Relief and I think 200 or 250 dollars to
black lives matter thank you so much
well those guys they say go see the
Aberdeen paper let's get in here I just
got killed by I got killed to Swan Paul
Swan Lake
we all got everything pig farmers let's
go do that
oh no I got it Swan pool and my hat got
blown off thanks a lot
oh I have a feeling my cabal gives five
bucks and says hey Cal pokes okay I'm
just going in now uh awk doodle five
bucks hey guys love your work
thanks for all the good moments should
we see if we can squeeze by him and
start that mission Lucy I kill him Papo
butter I was just about to kill reijin
mess with the bull good ol my lamb chase
oh but Jake no I didn't get the cut see
your Posse leader has launched the
mission will begin shortly a lot more
than is normal Irish voice because he
grew up have you got there Roger
the stage here to sin estates an egg
with silver
[Music]
Josefin James 20 bucks you guys also
been rented to is fantastic in the past
six months I've managed to put nine
hundred hours in you could add any
mission to read dead 2 companion mission
or full mission to game what would you
add would been like it if there have
been a special Dutch and author mission
so Alex I'll go to you first
what kind of mission would you like to
have seen oh man that is a great
question
ok maybe all the ladies like Sadie
taking out the ladies from the gang or
from art from the camp and just going
out on a little ride and maybe you know
they're all badasses in their own right
and I adore every one of them but just
you know perhaps uh spa seeing up and
going for I don't know two to four
something something like would have been
cool just just all the women look just
like a similar Leni mission just going
out on the town can you imagine us all
getting drunk together I kind of want to
see everyday you know he's doing they
were onto something great question Ben
Roger oh I fell I fell off Jeff I'm so
sorry Jeff uh Ben Roger a special Dutch
Arthur mission oh there was one that got
cut that was kind of fun where we take
out yeah the Boston bounty hunters on a
chain we spent a lot of time on that
that was gonna be oh I hate that guy cut
oh stop but it got cut because I guess
they just couldn't get it up to the
snuff and to kill your babies you know
you can't put everything in yeah
but as for you know I don't I I do my
best not to want what I don't have so I
don't know that I need another mission
with Arthur and I will say that that
mission where we did get to do I have to
rinse the plastic with many of my staff
in these stagecoaches on my own I'm I'm
behind the stagecoaches okay let's get
these guys do we just kill all these
people
it's oh my god I got attack by mountain
line okay
Oh No
so I mean damn Josephine for the 900
hours that's incredible yeah must be
maxed out $1 from anonymous hope it
helps collectively every little helps
and on one eye are 5 dollars and 55
cents love are dead thanks to all the
cast can watch a shout out the first
iron ranges the first iron rangers
perfect $10 thank you in the team rock
stuff your hard work and giving us
experience of a lifetime one which lines
I mean when you get recognized or when
people ask you for shoutouts which lines
of your characters to people usually
come at us do you think people really
like Lenny I did not anticipate that
some people asked me to cough and they
really enjoy that too I did not
anticipate that either
but you know you never know because on
the day you're doing it you're not
thinking this is gonna be your thing
that's gonna haunt me the rest of my
life say in Tahiti or I have a plan find
out later yeah yeah that's fair Alex
what about you I you're you're the only
one of these fools that I trust and I
get a lot of my name is Denae Sadie not
lady a couple others like their good
quotes but the little guys or just
really asking me to say that the only
good O'Driscoll is a dead O'Driscoll I
mean it's true it is true Barbara
Kennelly
$50 this game is truly an experience of
a lifetime so glad to be part of it
Thank You Benjamin Baron Davis Roger
Clark the touching lives of so many in a
positive way Alex McKenna too much
respects you all thank you so much it's
a lovely tribute Jordan letovsky $20
love Red Dead Redemption to the story
gives me chills to this day actually
playing through it again and back at
blank just one night off on Micah
and see how he likes it yeah three bucks
from Sandra Elizabeth some hugs from
Estonia oh oh this is this is a very
kind of bittersweet one Jamie Milne $15
hi from Scotland my sister passed away
two weeks after Red Dead 2 came out
playing through the story got me through
the toughest time thank you stay well
everyone well that's beautiful comfort
sending love
I lost your life yeah I was relied
Jordan $25 such a moving story and
everyone involved proved how talented
they are thanks for an unforgettable
game thank you guys you guys are awesome
we just completed the mission look at us
I was having doubts for a bit there I
was able to get that last bag because I
took so long to get there I only counter
two baddies but I got them pretty good
do we want to go to the Aberdeen pig
farmers yeah so I I have a request can
we stop by a post-office first because
I've got a lot of horse food and food
and whatnot that I need to sells upon
Sally $50 you guys are beyond amazing
this game changed my life and I can't
thank you enough I'll hopefully meet you
all at a convention very soon can you
guys say hi to our goddess Rachel and
the feet finger darlings Rachel and
finger darlings hello hi Rachel Oh
Rachel it's good to be a goddess I
expect here's a funny story the Aberdeen
siblings the dude he's actually if you
remember the beginning of gta5 when
you're robbing the bank in north yankton
he's the same actor as the guy who gets
shot in the throat when they're trying
to escape from the cops same phone okay
really funny guy really funny guy doing
that scene was really funny
okay so pig farmers are far away that's
right we can I'm trying to see where is
there a well we're in front of a fast
travel point we could let's do that
so we need to fast travel to UM I think
the nearest spot is emerald ranch at
that emerald ranch it was our fast
travel though our own station yeah let's
do that I did that without even
consulting the map that's right
where is the festival around here I
think there's a post office at Emerald
station too right yeah there is there is
just perfect
I was still still new things let's get
through someone donations Elizabeth your
hands ten fifty bucks I love you so much
Alex you gave so much life to Sadie she
was such a strong character
Roger simply amazing work loved your
audio book Benjamin you are such a
wonderful actor and Dutch man I love
that character thank you so much glad
you like the audiobook and thanks so
much donating it's so you guys get such
sweet messages and truly are the
greatest I couldn't be more blown away
by how truly and intensely and
passionately they love the game and yeah
everybody has just been so kind and this
just proves it I mean thank you for
contributing to these two very very very
important charities and organizations so
they were all Direct Relief donations
I'm gonna read off a lot of the black
lives matter ones we've had so many come
in these ones don't have messages on
unfortunately or at least there's no way
to access them so let's give these guys
a great shout out for the great money
they've been donating so just yeah Jason
eager off $25 Jordan Mazza ma 25 bucks
Rachel Robinson $10 thank you Rachel
Rachel
Tyler Rodriguez they donated before
another $25 and I mentioned this earlier
but I'd back TV $250 to black lives
matter and over and that we go to the
Aberdeen pig farm so
love it incest is best
[Laughter]
fabien wall thousand ten dollars
Jessie Mikulski ten dollars Jessie it
Chris Bailey $1 I don't like you close
to the Sun there young man
Carla Henzell $10 Alison pilly $25 thank
you I'll say well done Alison thank you
Matt Kasim table Ritz key I hope I
pronounced that correctly $25 mvhr dat
hunter Sweeney $1 uncle
Tacitus $10 from Patrick tor no $100
sorry two bucks from Tyler Daniels this
is a Red Dead name here Greta Van de
lijn my mother at 75 played through Red
Dead Redemption - whoops no Lucy you got
to read she wrote this great I say about
it and everything seven she went to a
convention in Boston uh my hometown and
she saw me and robbed her on a panel and
saw all the amazed and Red Dead fans and
my mother thought if they could do it
she could do it and she wanted to know
what it was all about and she came from
top to bottom she didn't get a hundred
percent but she finished the story
Wow I'm gonna say you can find I'm sure
your Google that you can find the SF
which mom is retired but she was a arts
educator mom for her whole life and she
she wrote a beautiful essay just about
her experience with the game that I wait
a second why didn't you send that to the
group were all in a group chain it's
pretty phenomenal and she she she went
viral she was they wrote about it in
Germany they wrote about it and Poland
they Haley Sheeran $5 Katherine Thomason
$50 Katherine thank you
Christopher kazna $2 Oh Maggie Fallon $5
Bruce $15 for boo Bruce Mansfield my dog
is chewing on a thing shouldn't you know
I was gonna say he's a special guest of
the stream the real special guest Jade
boots $2 nice Jade with xx $1 nice
Christopher cosna again $25
I'll get this over this page and then
we'll do the mission Gabriella by lazer
team a $10 Gabriella
Theodore coma $1 nice one Theodore
$5 Sally Biel 50 bucks
thank you amazing so excited this is
wonderful yeah
Gabriella ballast air again $10
Melanie Harry $10 Thank You Melanie you
are a goddess among people thank you she
got the hot tip there Fe $25 yeah
Catherine another $25 Thank You
Catherine Catherine that's great I'm
Maggie Fallon $5 Maggie that's awesome
we fantastic everyone thank you so much
thank you to the cast of redhead 2 for
joining us to play some games we'll
having a lot of fun as the the Friends
of Gavin and right dead online if you'd
like to donate the links are on the
screen there's a been so many be coming
through so we're gonna try and shout
everyone out but now let's meet some Pig
[Music]
what do you think with the extra curve
[Music]
no we're just simple farmers now last we
heard they was fixin to take a
stagecoach north from San Denis towards
Van Horn well I think that's a yes
this is the day to be thankful for you
know what
another thing I'm gonna finish off the
stew Oh it'll be stone cold
[Music]
well I would eat your meat off a dirty
floor I noticed we broke $20,000 in
blacklivesmatter just now I was gonna
mention I was gonna mention we're like
three dollars away from 20,000 before
the cutscene but then I decided reign
until after and we like 50 more dollars
the best so awesome we gotta get for
these stagecoaches they're heading north
from Sansa knee I think they might be
heading towards Ana's burg all right you
guys have such good map knowledge yeah
we got a bit of a ways to go yeah if you
stick to the roads all right I'll read
out some what donations is we're on the
way if I it's good that it's Jake's game
play here cuz in case I go into a into a
tree
Austin BMX underscore why whitey I'm
assuming YouTube $20 love read
to hope to see y'all on the prairie
sometime you to Austin thank you so much
thank you
Gil $2 can Roger say nobody eats in this
classroom but me nobody eats yeah nobody
eats in this classroom but me
we are guys hey you got the drivers in
the armed guards okay I can do that
Oh
Alessandro filari our very own $30.00
loved your performances in Red Dead
Redemption - it was my favorite ensemble
in a game in a very long time
author can you tell Dutch how badly you
need the money you need the money what
we need sorry say that again uh so
that's how badly you need the money
that's you don't know how bad I needed I
need currency and large amounts and a
request 20 bucks and gentleman a Russell
we get your best Lenny's again things
this is a common theme everyone loves
Lenny we should also give a shout-out to
heron Adkins who the wonderful actor who
plays Lennie yes where is this other
stagecoach oh oh I'm coming I've got my
gun deliver the target to Aberdeen pig
farm all right I'll see you guys there
yeah heading there with mine it's well
looks like we got one running away too
wowthat's now we got we got seen
somebody's reported to crime no
busybodies look the friends of gavin
have more pressing matters to deal with
then the the likes of the law uh targets
he's on the back of my [ __ ] no it's
this guy i'm chasing him get the coward
one dude right I got him
Jade again three dollars it's ok people
always get my name from I'm sorry
in any case could you give it LLL give a
greeting to Pamela and Nico Souza Pamela
Nico yeah yeah Mille Enrico Yoda The
Hobbit
gives two dollars beating read dead 2
last year helped me and deal with my
grief after my stepfather died last year
thank you all so much for your amazing
performances thank you
I'm sorry about your stepfather he rest
in peace very sorry the heat getting a
lot of messages about uh uh how you how
the game has helped people and these
really dark times what do you kind of
what do you say - did you ever imagine
it would have that much of an impact on
people no it was I was definitely
unanticipated but the fact that we've
been able to be part of something that
helps people process whatever that's
going on in their lives
it's that was unanticipated and it's
just I think it's testament
the fact that how awesome gaming can be
both you know the community and and for
what it means to us to your own and we
were working on this game you know I've
been would always say that I think this
is like a novel this is like a big novel
and and like a big novel you can totally
immerse yourself into it and that
immersion can really help you sometimes
especially if you're you know things
aren't going so well in other areas so
to be part of something to help that
helps other people like that is just
unbelievable it's also it's an
incredible honor but the other thing is
we were on it for so long when I first
met Roger his first son had just been
born and then by the end of the process
his son Rory was also born so many
people had kids there were marriages
that came together there was a we did
become all of us together so much a part
of each other's lives and now to be able
to intersect with people and become a
part of their lives at least in some
small way you know connecting families
generationally father's to sons and
mothers to daughters and all of it is
just an honor to just be a small part of
something that people love so well it's
amazing yeah and I think to how
emotionally invested you get in the game
and you feel to Arthur so that when what
happens happens for those who haven't
finished it I'll just be thank a lot of
the feedback that I got was that players
had never cried in a game before and
because it's so emotional they were
given the permission to actually have
feelings which is not something
unfortunately society IRL really
promotes and I feel like that permission
is something we all need because grief
is not something that the general public
is comfortable about or talks about and
so when you can talk about crying
because of the loss of whomever in the
game I just say I think it really
resonated and I think it's a it's very
important on to read out this this
donation so Ally matthean $20 I'm a
frontline worker in a hospital what a
tough couple of months say what you guys
are doing is awesome keep up the good
work been playing Red Dead since the
first one came out what you guys have
done is awesome and love you thank you
carry on big city thanks for all that
you're doing an absolute here and I
think everybody should keep in mind that
one way we can honor the sacrifice of
the people on the frontlines it's really
easy wear a mask in public that's it
and wash it well yeah wash your hands
stupid but wear a mask
please there we go we've got the third
hostage magic Russian a it's so pretty I
just can't get over how beautiful it is
I just like start it up from time to
time not even to really do anything
other than just kind of ride around on
my horse hunt a little bit and just get
lost in it totally ok so we have about a
half hour left of the stream we can go
fast yeah that's gonna read quickly and
we have so many donations to get through
to so I'll do that when we run on route
to the next place so you can either go
see Bonnie McFarlane lovely Bonnie all
the black Belle I'm open for Isaac I
what is the next donation say okay yeah
let's leave it up to the chat or you can
all find a pub somewhere go get wasted
and do some yeah Valentine's seems to be
pretty violent
earlier today getting a drink on and
beating up some folks should we go to
Valentine let's do it alright yeah
alright
wait points down I know the way
I don't need to look at the map Jeff
give me a boy off we go
you know another crazy thing ever
working on the game for so long I
remember some scenes we do it we do half
of it and then we wouldn't finish it for
like three years later and some
sometimes I would see I would work with
an actor and then three years later we
would meet up again and they look at me
and they go you're still we're finishing
off the scene that we did three years
ago oh my god like that she first showed
up maybe without a year into it we
didn't finish all of her scenes until
maybe the last year so she would come up
in every once in a while she had gotten
married I mean there's some finished
scenes in the game that that include
performance capture that we did at the
very beginning work in the booth where
we would have the helmet which had a
microphone and a camera at the end of it
so it was getting everything our face
was doing so we do booth work capture
work different capture work an actor had
to be replaced for one reason or another
and so a new performance comes in and
then the dialogues changed because we
set it in stand and E as opposed to
Valentine and it all comes together and
what Rockstar does is so magical because
it feels like it's all just one thing it
doesn't feel cobbled together it feels
immediate yeah ayushman deep $2 this is
the best game I've ever played every
time I feel a bit down in life I come
back home and walk around the Grizzlies
and everything picks up thank you all of
you associated in this amazing project
yeah this is beautiful country sandbox
are $30 high from the good old Nebraska
thanks for all the work you put into
this masterpiece and what you're doing
to raise money for both great causes
Cheers too much Nebraska oh it's a very
special one this is from Barbara $50
because it's my 50th birthday she says
I'm a huge fan of bands could you please
ask him to stay I had a goddamn plan
absolutely it would be my honor Barbara
happy birthday
don't ever forget I had a goddamn plan
[Laughter]
Catherine $20 thank you so much for
doing this
the Red Dead Redemption series is one of
my favorites thanks Catherine captain
Kayla pill $3 best actors playing the
best game an offer good cause love you
all and of course the game hopefully
when kovat is over we can finally get to
farming mangoes in Tahiti hopefully yes
[Music]
max five dollars max able puns can I
please receive a birthday greeting from
all three of you it'll be next-- one
thing happy birthday max happy birthday
max max have a great birthday and a
great year ahead the training Oh
shankam Healy I hope I pronounced that
correctly $5.00 hey guys I'm on my
second playthrough Red Dead - I've been
playing off and on for the last year
anyway I'm getting close to hundred
percent in the game
that I'm trying to prolong the ending
for as long as possible
thinking of the game being open makes me
a little teary-eyed
any advice thank you good luck with the
dominoes if you're doing 100% yeah I was
gonna start over yeah exactly there's
always a third playthrough what was it
like you know all you've been working on
it for years and what was it what was it
that final day that final shoot like the
or we yeah I remember the last day and
performance capture was me and Rob and
it was them not to spoil anything but it
was one of the farewells so it's very
apropos that that was the last day and
then my last day and the sound booth was
a couple of months later and finished
off a bottle of Middleton with a
wonderful producer Johnny finish which
was awesome
yes the law is the longest job I've ever
had
I'd be curious to know whether that will
ever be beat you know five years is a
long time but whiskey right now I'm
gonna get some too I'm gonna get drinkin
I I cried I cried a little bit I have to
you know yeah it was a lot it's just
it's sad it's sad to say goodbye and in
the way that it was like this exciting
thing every time I got the call that
there was going to be work it was you
know such a joy to go and then to know
that that would happen anymore was
pretty devastating but also it meant
that this thing we've been working on we
finally get to see it was exciting did
you I mean I see you obviously struck up
a strong friendship during recording and
did you imagine you'd still be this
close you know two years down the line
yeah I think I did I mean at a certain
point
you spend so much time working with such
a fine group of people on something that
that I mean it's still kind of
overwhelming to even think about how
many people have engaged with the work
we were a part of where we're gonna be
united by this project for the rest of
our lives and I tell you I've been on
some ensembles that are less fun than
others I'll leave it there but I will
say that this is such an amazing group
of people I'm very proud to be among
them Oh somebody's throwing that was me
that was me I'm just gonna go sorry I
just saw you walk in Roger holding the
lighted stick of time well I had their
courtesy that's good that's good yeah
but now I can't order a drink from the
bartender with Rogers that will that
happen stick them up oh no I can't I got
the cops after me oh here we go I'm
setting a new a new beam oh I like it
it's raining all right here we go
this last rapscallion five dollars love
the game love you guys happy to donate
for my 34th birthday then tell me to
have some god damn face what I need the
name last rapscallion last rapscallion
34 years old you better have some
goddamn face keep it oh we cleared out
the town
oh no that's you that's Lucy so whose oh
wait I've got I've got new amounts no oh
no don't I'm gonna do oh this guy's just
a Fed just might well good and someone's
shootin
I'm Jen on awkward dance I'm a big fan
I'm coming yeah yeah Andrew Harvey $10
you guys the absolute best
this game has helped me get through
tough times in my life I would love to
meet you all one day did you get to
improvise any scenes while working on
the game any scenes but we definitely
improvised a little bit sometimes you
know depending on what needed to occur
there there was maybe a wee bit of
ad-libbing but I mean again the writing
was so good that we didn't need to
monitor didn't really ask for it because
it was great yeah you guys yeah a little
bits here and there usually because of
the nature of the work if we had a
change or a thought occurred we get run
up and approved and then come back down
but there's a couple of things in there
that I'm proud to say I had to hand in
so it looks like the Friends of Gavin
have just completely gone off the rails
here by the way we're doing so well we
were helping people out and now now
we're just killing everybody you know
that's the way it is out west
oh I killed a horse fired but somebody
else killed another horse whatever all
these dead horses is about that's no
good
Queen Farina five dollars cheers from
the retreat my only request is for
someone to tell Jay the black Arabian
isn't the best horse I killed another
horse
I only use which like the best boss is
really Jeff - so I named all my horses
Steve so it's just Steve one two three
four well it depends it depends what
save we're talking my first save I only
had one horse that lasted me - Oh what
happened I'm kind Daisy oh no this is
this do sir rather quickly
yeah now us gave it foggy $10 thinking I
was they've been in a lot of us dreams
and donating a lot
Gabby gives five dollars this game
helped me get through a tough time
anytime I feel overwhelmed or a little
down I will still jump into red dead -
to help me cope process or relax thank
you guys and all the rockstar team from
so much making such a beautiful game can
I get a yeehaw from each oh wow I'm
gonna murderous rampage I was I was
clean until I revived you and then I
guess someone saw it and reported the
crime is he gave five dollars and said a
very nice message about me thank you
very much he said back was not a
donation
shout out to Lucy you're doing an
amazing job multitasking between playing
the game following the donations and
moderating the session your Testaments
your professionalism yeah you guys make
it so easy like I just have to point you
in a direction we all have a good time
and the chat has been has been really
great
oh this is a great question this is from
Patrick who gave $20 hey guys huge fan
thanks for spending
doing this what was the most hype moment
for your Red Dead Redemption to play
through the hype most hype moment like
just the moment I think what you just
saw something in the game and you're
like holy [ __ ] I can't believe you know
maybe a moment that you'd like a scene
that you've been really excited about
doing in Seoul for the first time in
action I think the first time I saw a
bit of gameplay was amazing for me I
remember being up in the snow and I was
looking at the snow tracks you know and
we were comparing it to what other games
that had snow snow tracks currently at
the time and it just blew my mind and
looking at the physics of the whole
world and the way that they designed it
little things that blew my mind would
like if you walk in the mud and it's
raining you see your footprints fill up
with water little details like that
which I I just don't see I hardly ever
see with other studios that's amazing I
remember that blowing my mind
Alex what about you two things come to
mind first when I saw the first a little
teaser trailer and the crackling of the
fire like the sound the way that it
looked I I think I got tears of my eyes
truly came it's already I didn't I don't
think I saw a single one of us just that
crackling it was just so so gorgeous and
then I think actually playing when there
was a dead carcass and I came back
around and it was still there like an
hour later you know in any other game
I've ever played that something
disappears it doesn't just stay that's
right but it's rock stairs oh can
someone help me I'm all tied up oh yeah
oh no I'm next to the bouncer poster I'm
oh you're dead I was gonna say a moment
that I remember being very hyped for was
when the gang goes up to the brave
weight mansion and you've got that music
playing and they're all lined up in the
camera kind of starts to panel a and I
just remember getting chills as I was
doing that
for me it was it was you know a lot of
the times while we were working on it
you get pages sometimes you get pages
the day they were written but sometimes
you'd have stuff for a long time and and
one of those was the all this stuff with
Angelo Bronte that I had I had it for
nearly a year before my god I'm spacing
on his name right now Jim Peary the
wonderful actor Jim Perry who plan
Jalloh Bronte but I had that material
for so long I loved it so much I was so
excited shoot it and then finally we got
to do it and so when we got into the
game and we get to the scene with the
alligator to be as light on spoilers as
I could be and the music swells and the
scene ends and it the whole scene that
whole thing put together I had to stop
the game and I immediately called our
director rod edge and just so many years
went into that and then to see it put
together with all the amazing work the
animators who I've gotten to see Jason
Barnes one of the guys I'd seen him
working on the alligators and and then
the music coming to get I mean just all
of that coming together and seeing that
sitting still gives me chills thinking
about the first time I got to see that
because it was we wanted it to be half
as good as it ended up being it's so
amazing what you know the whole process
has been just extraordinary working on
this amazing work of art but that hyped
me up pretty damn good Julianna $5 Roger
please say sure Camille $5 my friend I
play this game every night we are both
huge fans if it's possible could you say
some kind words her name is Julie and
she's having some hard times thanks for
everything
love you all Oh Julie I'm sorry to hear
that you know every beginning has an end
it's alright girl you're gonna kill it
have a great summer and
you know if it ever gets too much you
could always you could always go online
no I just was gonna say stay strong keep
faith and I'm sorry yeah Julie listen
women are stronger than then we know
under no-one understands so deep breaths
drink water move your body I like to
dance and ya the mornings always
brighter oh that's very sweet thank you
everyone
Maggie Fallon can Dutch please shout out
five ha
so five dollars can Dutch please shout
out happy birthday to Maggie
happy birthday to Maggie
happy birthday Maggie
Kelly $20.50 thank you for making a
masterpiece right that one was the first
and only game of Platinum's that's no
mean feat uh and happily waited the nine
years to do the same with Red Dead -
please don't hate the fifty cents - a
carrot for Jake's horse fantastic thank
you Jake please I'm gonna feed it right
now
oh this once in two dollars can we get a
hottie yeehaw and a god bless all of you
lovely people
yeah and God bless God bless and yeehaw
yeah god bless this is stuff oh this is
a great question oh so teeny $5 how did
Sadie get the scar on her forehead I
mean that's bad this is a great question
for me Hayley George was very teeny but
thank you I think I think they've
donated twice now so they have Holly
donated again
again two questions for y'all if you are
actually in the Old West how do you
think you would do and - my phone needs
a new voicemail message would y'all
please say one for me and if in a few
years you'll see a ranch called True
Grit livestock that's me
we'll have some steaks for you a full
name again
Holly borscht I think it's bourgeois B
oh you are G e o is ya we're just gonna
go with Harley for the sake of posterity
how you reached Harley he's not in right
now it's probably handling some cattle
you uh you a message she'll call you
right back cuz she's a good girl you've
reached Harley who leaves messages get
off the phone man texture another
question was if you actually in the Old
West how do you think you do yeah I
don't know if I do very well I like my
comforts too much I think I'd still be
an actor so well I guess oh yeah there's
some real similarities to Sadie actually
I am I have a huge garden I'm so
essentially a good farmer I'm riding
horses since I was little
I'm stronger than I look and I can
handle a gun pretty well yeah my money's
on you I'm gonna be posting up with you
puttan don't don't contract any
uncurable diseases
need ya got about 10 minutes left so I'm
gonna like blast through some donations
do you guys want it should we have a
drink to celebrate such a successful
stream I'm already at me to order a beer
and a whiskey at the same time though
been the only part of red that isn't
realistic can't have a beer and a
whiskey chaser dancer jig while holding
whiskey which I could actually do jump
until occurs thank you
we got some scallions out out
rapscallions out back out front again I
think never mind we were doing the exact
same thing 10 minutes ago time time
moves fast people move on yeah well they
deserved it 15 no so $7 77 cents from
Daymond and just beat the game recently
after my nephew erased my game safe when
it first came out when I was just
missions away from the end a an amazing
acting yeah thank you so much
Kelly sue 100 bucks to black lives
matter thank you Wow Michelle McCammon
50 bucks Thank You Michelle
Timothy dent 50 bucks ice was Adam
Blackmore $10 thank you and Patrick
Muscat Pasquale $7 77 cents yeah we were
playing
Final Fantasy 7 remake with Breanna
White who plays Aerith a couple weeks
ago and obviously people were doing 777
then that makes sense
I just did a little deep dive into the
YouTube chance and there's somebody
named Aldridge and Ritchie's and very
sweet somebody's donation button wasn't
working and Ritchie's donated on behalf
of Aldrich and so thank you guys very
own rubric Monday he has been in all of
us stream chats
he's the moderator he's a great video
producer so Thank You Richie for your
hard work
Thank You Richie Thank You Richie it's
very sweet
Christine mills $25 I say that one um
Jake Bradley $5 nice one Jake big Harry
Jones Christ $20 Harry that's amazing
fill beverage $50 nice one though well
got some beverages right now yeah
Elizabeth hope $5 Thank You Elizabeth
although this was from a while ago so
I'm gonna refresh enough I don't think
you'll have enough time to get through
all of them I'm gonna try yeah so we did
Elizabeth hope Donald $25.00 Donald
Claunch iswow Benjamin lor take $10 fine
name there man
Luke Lee $25 Luke you're awesome Thank
You
bfsd Kesey $2 thank you I thank you uh
Kaylin Gonzales 25 nice one Kaylin
Carlos Eduardo games 25
IRLS Denise Solman 25 Thank You Denise
amazed all right from chat so this is
from Richie very sweet $10 Nathaniel
Sutcliffe three dollars two dollars
[Music]
jasmine five dollars in Stephanie ten
dollars so these are all for black lives
matter thank you so much everyone
only have a couple of minutes so I'm
gonna ask one or two more questions
so Leah Lou says howdy
could you give Red Dead s envious shouts
out he's a big fan of ready to would
love if you guys give him a shout out
love you Red Dead snv big shout out to
Red Dead snv I lost four laughs nice one
bear doesn't be and oh here we go
Josephine James eyes a great name sounds
like a superhero $10 nice one Josephine
I know I already donates it but just
thought of another question what was
your favorite location in rented to your
point of interest and Alex a full lady's
mission would have been amazing
favorable location insane I mean I never
thought there would be such an urban
setting in a cowboy game but they pulled
it off amazingly oh Shannon hmm
I always like new Austin I always like
new Austin
I love how different sound of me feels
like it just feels like a completely
perfect but very separate place but it
also feels like part of the world but it
very different part of it I love
something me yeah all right I am so
sorry everyone we're gonna have to wrap
it up if we didn't get to your shoutout
I'm so sorry where there was so many of
you um a huge thank you to Roger Clark
Alex weekend and Ben pyrin Davis for
what has been such a fun stream
I really appreciate like we all do we
appreciate you guys taking the time
answering question partying up is the
Friends of Gavin this has been so much
fun you guys have been awesome - thank
you for having us and thank you to
everyone who donated man yes
donations been crazy those links are
gonna stay open if you have a chance of
winning donate some more money they stay
open we'll be promoting them everywhere
someone just killed my horse
organizations that really matter Jake
yeah thank you
wait can everyone find you let's do like
quick social shoutouts if you want to
follow the amazing cast of right ever
attention to watch I'll start with you
what was that sorry all right my twitter
is our clark 98 and my instagram is
rolling ROG ro ll ing ROG and I got a
YouTube channel as well you can find it
just by searching my name Alex McKenna
Instagram sort of is more my speed and
that is max magpie I'm Ben and I am ACTU
de TLO DAA on Twitter and my Instagram
is Big Ben Davis thank you everyone
again for watching and donating thank
you very much to the cast of Red Dead
Redemption - and you know for all the
latest on all the biggest games you know
to keep it on gamespot tomorrow
charity stream we've got Naomi Kyle
playing some rocket League tune in it's
gonna be fun time see you next time
thank you cheers guys